welcome to data science engineer
salary skills my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that is www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead if you have any
questions feel free to visit our website
or post below we do have people
monitoring this station who will try to
answer your questions
so what's in it for you today well first
we're going to start with an
introduction to
data science what exactly is what are we
looking at who is a data science
engineer
data science engineer skill set data
science engineer job roles
data science engineer salary trends keep
in mind that a lot of these different
terms and we're focusing on data science
our last video was on machine learning
engineer a lot of these terms overlap
greatly so understanding both what your
focus is
and what you enjoy doing and what's out
there in the job market are important
so let's take a look at the introduction
to data science
data science is a systematic way to
analyze
a massive amount of data and extract
information from it
and you can see here a couple examples
of pulling information
from the cloud from files on computers
or saved documents
from assorted databases and we want to
reduce that down
to some form of information we can
actually use so we look at the data
science
is mainly needed for better decision
making either a or b
do we buy or do we sell our stock do we
market uh which group are we going to
market to predictive analysis
what will happen next this is probably
the most commonly used when we talk
about data science and people are
talking about that as predictive you
know it's just
are we going to have a good return next
year we're gonna have a bad return
what's going on with the business
are we gonna have a lot of forest fires
this year are we not those kind of
things what are we gonna predict
pattern recognition is there any
important hidden information
in the pattern and this is across the
board we might look at all this
different information
crimes tracking down crimes and you know
in our police force
this is becoming more and more common
where they look for commonality and then
they're able to go in there and say okay
we need to investigate what's going on
here because this group of people has
the same
kind of input off of facebook and
everything else as
these other five people who created
committed certain crimes and we look at
data science we can answer a lot of
questions as well
how many viewers like the same movies
which route will help me reach faster
that's the traveling salesman program
you know how can i hit the most spots in
the shortest amount of time
will this ac work for three years or
fail earlier
yes or no is this a good buy or not who
will win the world cup
so who is a data science engineer
are you a data science engineer or are
you going to be looking for a different
field
what exactly is a data science engineer
well a data science engineer is someone
who has
programming experience in python and r
expert level knowledge
ability to write proficient codes and
they
we have python and r i'm going to say
python or
r once you come really proficient at one
language
transferring those skills into another
one is usually fairly
easy now r is a little different because
it is an
analytics platform so going from python
to r
if you already know the data analytics
and python moving to r is pretty easy
now r doesn't have all the other code
that you can
access with python there's so many
things you can do with python that are
not data analytics
so it's important to keep in mind that
you should probably be pretty
well-rounded in python and really have a
solid foundation in r
or have a solid foundation in r and be
well-rounded in another programming
language where you really get the
programming side of it
strong sql and big data experience so
you have to have a strong coding skill
with hands-on
big data experience and of course we're
showing sql here
most commonly used whether you're using
a microsoft sql server or mysql server
you can also start thinking hadoop and
spark
in big data access hadoop file system
is not a huge jump if you've already
learned your sql and you've already
learned your basics in coding
hadoop sits on top of all that and does
a wonderful job creating huge clusters
of data
but you really need to know your sql
because that is so common in most of the
large companies now accessing their data
and an ability to visualize
models and troubleshoot code of the
models this is a kind of an interesting
one because
these models are can get very
complicated so you got to be able to
break them down
into something that you can put the
pieces together and digest each of the
pieces
so being able to visualize these models
is very important and then being able to
drill down and
troubleshoot the different models or the
pieces in those models
they need to be a versatile problem
solver equipped with strong analytical
and quantitative skills
a self-starter with a strong sense of
personal responsibility and technical
orientation
this is an interesting one because when
you talk about data science engineer
it's such a new field that most
companies don't have it well defined
they don't know what they're looking for
you might not even know what you're
looking for you might have an idea and
you're looking for patterns but where do
those patterns lead you
so you really need that self-starter
side to jump in there and figure out
where to go
and be able to communicate that back to
the team and there we go we have a
strong
product intuition data analysis skills
and
business presentation skills and this is
what's talking about is
you got to bring that back to the team
so if you don't have a strong product in
tuition if you don't know what's going
on with the company
what they need and where you're going
with your analysis it's going to be a
dead end
and you got to be able to present that
to the shareholders to your
co-workers which leads us to great
teammate with excellent interpersonal
skills
and this is kind of a strange one
because you spend so much time behind
your desk so you have to be able to kind
of float between
you're studying all the data and being
able to explain this to people
in simple terms that they can understand
no one wants somebody to come up and say
yeah the p score and the f score is this
that and the other thing
and you might have two people in the
room understand you you have to be able
to sit down and explain
what that means and why so let's take a
look at the data science skill set
we talk about data science engineer
skill set we're talking about
database knowledge statistics
programming tools
data wrangling probably the least
favorite and most used
machine learning data visualization and
then the touch on big data
and so we'll start with database
knowledge the most
common database is of course your sql
structured query language
think rows and columns it's an essential
language for extracting a large amount
of data from data sets so knowledge of
the sql is
mandatory for data science engineers and
you can see there's tools required
there's the
oracle database i mentioned my sql
server
microsoft sql server teradata there are
so many different forms of sql
and it'll just keep coming back and
coming back so if you don't have a solid
basic understanding of sql go get it
very important because it will come up
you know it's if you don't know it it's
going to bite you and statistics of
course we are you know that's what this
is all about is figuring out and
predicting things so you need to know
your statistics
statistics is a subset of mathematics
that deals with collecting
analyzing and interpreting data
therefore data scientist needs to know
statistics so you need to understand
your probabilities and what that means
and what the p score means and the f
score and means and
mode and median all that information
standard deviation all of those you need
to
be aware of and then we get into the
programming tools
and i mentioned this earlier a little
bit but you need to master any one of
these specific
programming languages programming tools
such as r python
sas are essential to perform analytics
in
data and again you know you can move in
there and you can be an expert in just r
you can be an expert in just sas and a
little bit you can be an expert in
python
because most of these when we're talking
about data science and data wrangling
you really kind of get down to the point
where you really need to have a full
programming language
at least the basics and if you're going
to be working in
data science python right now is the
main one but you know there's also java
c
plus so you need to know a solid
language at least the basics of it so
you can understand how to do basic
iterations and things like that
i always find that interesting that my
sister who runs a university data
analytics center that's the first
question she asks for
people candidates to come and work for
is how do you iterate through data you'd
be amazed at how many people don't
understand
that very basic concept in programming
so when we look at r
r is a free software environment for
statistical computing and graphs
supports most machine learning
algorithms for data analytics like
regression
association clustering and etc python
python is an open source general purpose
programming language and there's our
general purpose i was just talking about
you need to know a little bit about
python libraries like numpy and scipy
are used in data science
scipy yeah numpy and scipy are very
central to python and i'd throw pandas
in there also
that module those are very central to
working with python
and data analytics and then sas sas can
mine
alter manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources
it can perform statistical analysis on
the data
so where r is the open source platform
sas is more like the paid for
platform and so it has some things more
automated because people
are paying for it developing it but it's
also if you really start using it as a
company you're gonna have to pay for
it where r is free store is a free
software python is also open source and
free to use
so we're gonna talk a little bit about
data wrangling and i mentioned earlier
that is
both the probably people's least
favorite
aspects of data science and also
probably one of the places
you spend the most time so we talk about
data wrangling it is a process of
transforming
raw data into an appropriate format to
make it useful for analytics
and it involves cleaning raw data
structuring raw data
and enriching raw data and this gets
interesting because you'll get stuck
on something like in python you might
get stuck on something that
is a date time based on an integer 64
numpy set you might not know what all
those terms mean because you work in r
or something like that but you get the
point that it's all one particular
format and then you have to figure out
how to switch it so that the computer
can see it correctly in whatever format
you're using or whatever analytics
platform you're using
knowledge of machine learning techniques
such as supervised machine learning
decision trees linear regression knn etc
is useful for
few job roles so this is kind of
interesting because sometimes that's the
center of the job role of a data
scientist
and sometimes you just have to be able
to apply
the programming skills to it so you can
get the answer and let somebody else
fine-tune your machine learning
techniques so it really
depends on what it is you're working
with and you can see here we have
our nearest neighbor set up where it
groups things together that look alike
linear regression you're drawing a line
through the data or curve
so you can predict what the next value
is going to be
and then our nice decision tree which
starts splitting things up and says you
know it's sunny out yes let's go
swimming
no it's raining we're not gonna go
swimming yes it's sunny out we might go
swim
it's raining uh we'll stay indoors yes
we'll walk the dog no so you have a
decision tree that helps figure out
how you get to the end result so
decision trees can be pretty powerful
and data visualization data
visualization is the study and creation
of visual representation of data
data visualization uses algorithms
statistical graphs
plots information graphics and other
tools to communicate
information clearly and effectively this
one
you really have to master as a data
science this one you really have to
master as a data scientist
and there certainly are so many
different tools to use to visualize it
but when you're communicating a picture
is worth a thousand words
when you can put a picture up and and
people can look at and go oh
i see what's going on that's worth a lot
more than saying yeah yeah this is good
people hear that and they just kind of
go okay it's good but why
and you might say you know okay these
numbers make it look good no people want
something they can see
and there certainly is uh tabloo is
probably
one of the most popular ones out there
caleb view
power bi google data studio
um in python there's um the pi kit
and seaborn there's all kinds of
different options for visualization
you need to master probably at least one
or two of them
so you understand how they work and how
they're different
and then big data big data is a massive
amount of data which cannot be stored
and processed using traditional methods
big data has various benefits like
access to social data can enable
organizations to
tune their business strategies big data
can improve customer experience
uh and so we're usually when you say big
data we're almost
always talking about hadoop and apache
spark it used to be hadoop
as your file system so that's how you
store all your data going across the
nodes and there certainly are other ways
to store it
when we talk about hadoop we're usually
talking about at least 10 terabytes of
data when you're dealing with a hadoop
file structure and then you can
use spark where hadoop processes on and
off the hard drive so it's continually
reading and writing to the hard drive
spark is running in your ram
and so when you're doing a very
intensive data process
you'll run a spark setup which will
spread those processes over multiple
computers
and of course now the two combine and
spark sits on top of hadoop and you get
your big data there's also
talent tableau has its own server set up
there's splunk uh cassandra you'll hear
the cassandra database pentaho i'm not
even sure how to pronounce that one
it's not one i've worked with certainly
there's a lot of options for big data
the two big players are of course hadoop
and spark and even your sql servers and
mysql servers will spread across
five different servers and you can be
talking about big data across five
servers with those pulling them into say
apache spark to do your high-end
processing and then there's
non-technical skills
probably the most important one in data
science and any of our data analytics
is intellectual curiosity updating
knowledge by reading contents and
relevant books on trends in data science
this is such there's so much going on in
this field and it's exploding now
that it's hard to keep track of it all
uh so you really need to have that
curiosity
in the data science probably even more
so than a lot of other fields
but i would say in just today's world
you need intellectual curiosity
because things are changing so rapidly
in today's world the way that it's going
with our technology
understanding how the problem solved can
impact
the business business acumen this is the
one where a lot of people kind of skip
over you have to have a little business
sense if you don't know how it's going
to impact the business
you're going to be in trouble why do
they want to even pay you to be there
unless they know what's going on and
they're getting something in return
so this is your bottom line for your
paycheck is
what's going on with the business how is
this going to impact the business what
are you doing for them
and communication skills companies look
for someone who can clearly and fluently
translate technical findings to a
non-technical team
and i've talked about this a bunch and i
i can't even iterate this enough
if you are struggling with your
communication skills
work on building them they don't have to
be you know this isn't rocket science
where you have to know all these
complicated terms what you need to do is
take the complicated terms you know from
data science
and reduce that down to something that
anybody can understand
so when you come up and you have you
know knn
no one knows what k n is you know unless
they're in data science
nearest neighbor looking for things that
match together you got to explain that
to people who do not have the technical
skill
in the data science arena and a data
science engineer needs to work with
everyone in the organization including
customers
so it's teamwork and that's always one
that throws people for a loop
but ultimately you are analyzing your
customers information
and so sometimes getting in there and
rolling up your sleeves
if you're let's say you're doing data
analysis for the sales team and you're
backing a sales team
you might have to get in there and go
start making some sales and making some
phone calls and see what it's like what
is that team doing
when they call 15 people in cold calls
and then they do a follow-up two weeks
later or three weeks later which one
works better
two or three does it work better to call
and send a fax
call and send an email you know when
should you show up in person if it's
that kind of business
so working with everybody including the
customer is very important with the data
and
with this kind of setup and
non-technical skills for a data
scientist
so let's take a look at some of the
roles a data science plays in the job
market
let's drill in there just a little bit
here so when you have a data scientist
they're going to perform predictive
analysis and identify trend and patterns
that can help in better decision making
companies hiring data scientists include
apple adobe
google microsoft i would say that's even
expanding down to smaller companies you
know where you're talking about only 100
employees or something like that they're
starting to look at data scientists
because they need them to come in
and be a part of that team and the role
is understanding challenges of a system
and offer
best solutions this should always be the
goal of a data scientist
is to be looking at the whole system and
then trying to find those patterns that
are going to best
enhance the company or the business or
the
whatever group maybe working with the
sales team or the marketing team and you
can see languages
pretty important to have a these are a
number of different languages and again
it depends on your own specialty
there's all kinds of different
variations but we have r
sas python matlab sql hive pig
spark you should have at least a
knowledge of all of these
maybe a python programmer never used r
download it go through the basics so at
least you know
what's going on in r versus python
because r is pretty powerful for doing a
very quick
display and then of course a lot of
things you can do in python you have to
be able to do queries on database from
time to time
create and modify algorithms which can
be used to reduce information from large
databases
and usually this is one of those things
you do at the beginning you set it up
and then you
kind of let it go until it breaks and
you have to go back and fix it because
your query isn't working that certainly
is a very common thing to
to have happen especially if you're
pulling data off the web and the
internet
and then we have some more companies
that are hiring data analysis like ibm
dhl hp and so we're talking about data
analyst
the role is responsible for a variety of
tasks such as visualization
optimization and processing large amount
of data
and so we're talking about a data
analyst we're also we're still talking a
lot of the same stuff but you'll see
we've now thrown in javascript and html
in here
because that's pretty common with a data
analyst versus a data scientist
and you can see that sql is still pretty
solid and also
um cc plus is pretty big so some
companies also use
java so i'd put java in the languages
also on that for a data analyst
and then you have a data architect
ensuring that data engineers have best
tools and systems to work with and so
companies hiring a data architect are
like visa logitech coca-cola
they create blueprints for data
management with the best
security measures i cannot highlight
that a data architect really spends a
lot of time with security measures
that's big how many hacks have we seen
in the last year on large companies have
lost data for millions of their
customers and how badly that affects
them
and we're looking at languages as you
see that sql
is pretty solid across all of these
under a data architect
xml that's one that a lot of the data
science jobs don't really
you don't see as much but you're going
to see more xml with a data architect
because there's a lot of xml files that
are that have your security measures
embedded in them and of course your hive
pig those are hadoop systems we're doing
some basic queries
so instead of doing the high end queries
you know how these simplified query
systems built into hadoop
and spark so if you're using big data
you're going to want to know your spark
also
and then we have our data engineer the
data engineer
updates the existing systems with better
version of the current technologies to
improve the efficiency of the databases
think admin here a lot of work tracking
down what version you're in
of the different programs what version
of python are you using what version of
r are using what version of c
plus plus so companies hiring data
engineers are like amazon
spotify facebook and they develop
construct
test and maintain architectures such as
databases and long-scale
processing systems and here we have our
languages our sql
r matlab sas spss python java ruby c
plus plus pearl hive
pig you pretty much as a data engineer
at this level when you talk about admin
and updating all these databases need to
know all the different stuff that's
being used
in the company and you're testing out
these structures to make sure they work
and so you really are talking admin
level
uh kind of setup so if you like spinning
up an admin onto
a google cloud service or amazon cloud
service
now you start to get an idea what we're
talking about because then you can test
it out up there and then you can bring
it back and update it to the company
statition creates new methodologies for
engineers to apply
and so when we look at this this is
where we're digging into the math of
which models to use
what setup's going to work what kind of
activation do we have on our neural
network
these little tweaks are going to make a
big difference
and we look for methodologies at a large
level what kind of data are we going to
be looking at how we're going to pull it
together
companies hiring a data engineer or
we're talking about stations we're
talking about linkedin
pepsico johnson and johnson and of
course these companies probably
hire a little bit of everything but they
have a lot of statisticians working for
them
and so we look at the role extract and
offer valuable reports from the data
clusters
through statistical theories and data
organization and the languages
across the board we're still seeing sql
our matlab sas spss
data that's a new one that i've seen in
some of the other roles
python pearl an older version and that
shouldn't be a surprise because a lot of
these companies probably built a lot of
the original packages on perl if you go
look at johnson and johnson and of
course your big data
hive pig and spark and then our database
administrator
i mentioned the other one is an admin
they're more an admin level for the
software itself
so administrator is another level some
of the tasks involved are monitoring
operating and maintaining databases
installation configuration defining
schemas training users etc
and this is interesting training users
because when you build a database and
you
define all the different tables that are
embedded in that database and how
they're all connected
the end user's got to have that
information otherwise you're in trouble
when we have companies hiring data
engineers
of course tabloo twitter reddit uh the
role
ensures that all the databases are
available to all relevant
users again a little security in there
what role do they have
is allowed in and not and is performing
correctly and is being kept
safe and you better be ready to spend
some time in security
because again that's a very big thing
nowadays with the number of people who
hack into these databases
and the languages are going to be
covered you have your
c sharp your java sql ruby on rails
xml again there's that xml because a lot
of your security is embedded in xml
files
um python all the main players depending
on what the company's using
data and analytics manager so when you
see manager that means that somebody's
going to sit on top
and organize the people underneath so
they're going to improve the business
process
as an intermediary between business and
i t
oh you better have some really good
communication skills for this one
some of the companies hiring a data
engineers are coursera
motorola slack and of course these
companies are hiring data scientists in
almost all of these fields
so the role oversees the data science
operations and assigns the duties to the
team
according to skills and expertise
so that's a big one you better be able
to communicate what's going on help your
team members
come out and be able to communicate with
other people so sometimes your job is
just being able to get people to talk to
each other the big thing on that
is is the whole communication line going
from one end to the other
because you can't communicate all the
information that everybody's working on
you have to pretty much come in there
and and help people communicate what
there's going on
and also know what they're up to without
being micromanagement
because that'll crash a company if you
micromanage everybody but if you just
let them do whatever they want and they
never talk to each other that will also
destroy the company you gotta find that
nice middle ground and you really have
to have an
overview of everything as a data and
analytics manager
one of the things i mean you know it's
good to have at least one or two
solid bases of programming under your
belt for a data analytics manager
but you do need to have a very general
understanding of all the different tools
being used so that you know what's going
on with your different team members
of course sql r sas java python matlab
all of those are big
business analytics so this is when
you're talking about your bi or your
business
intelligence and your business analytics
very important
to know this kind of a subdivision of a
lot of the other stuff we've talked
about a lot of the other roles we've
looked at
so you possess specialized knowledge of
their business domain
and apply that knowledge and analysis
specifically to the operation
of the business so you might be a
specialist in banking
you might be a genetics engineer
so you know about genetics you might
just be general business
helping the marketing so a lot of
companies hiring data engineer
oracle uber dell and the role act is a
link between the data engineers and the
management executives so it's very
similar to when you go back up here we
look at data analytics manager
a business and analytics is going to
also kind of fill that role in between
but they're more specialized in business
and you better know sql because we're
talking about a business specifically
most of the large companies are storing
their data that's
up and running right now that people are
accessing to purchase something on the
home depot website or
the uber they're logging in you better
know your sql it's very central to
business analytics so let's go ahead and
take a look at the data science engineer
salary trends and you'll see that our
source is glass door as we're pulling a
lot of our data from
average base pay is around 117 000
in the us the average salary and we look
at india we're talking about
950 000 a year and those are based on
some of them you need to go ahead and
dig deeper to find out what education
level versus entry level
but those are pretty solid base once
you're in the industry and once you
created your career in there and we look
at the job titles the most common
job title is data scientist business
intelligence manager is the second
greatest one
that's kind of good to note that's why
they put that up there as being its own
little subcategory of data science
managers a business intelligence manager
because it's such a high
level of jobs and then we looked at some
of the other ones data architect
business intelligence architect again
your bi
your business intelligence gets its own
ranking because it's such
a high level you know it's a business
people want their businesses to make
money so that's who's hiring
of course data engineer business
intelligence developer
business intelligence consultant
business intelligence analyst
business analyst and data analyst so you
can look at the data analysis being the
general one that doesn't go specific to
business
so if you're looking just for your
career as far as getting a job
probably should have some kind of
business understanding in the background
and again you know your companies want
to make money so they're going to hire
someone who knows business if
banking business if you specialize in
banking or retail if you specialize in
retail and marketing and you can see
here on the data science salary trends
and the growth and data science job
listings it's continually going up it's
um
since 2014 to 2012 we've gone from 400
to 600
that's a pretty big increase so you know
huge growth in this market it's one of
the biggest growing markets right now
for jobs
and careers thank you for joining us
with data science engineers salary
skills again my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
come visit our website to learn more
about what we have to offer in the
education and getting you
certified if you have more questions you
can also post them down below in the
youtube video we do have people
monitoring this channel
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here